כן.
אז בהסתכלות קדימה, מיטות ו-
qubit יהיו גן עדן חישובי יסודי
שבעזרתו נוכל להתמודד
עם בעיות מורכבות בעולם
אז בוא ננסה להבין את ההבדל ביניהם
ואיפה עולה הכוח של qubit
אם נסתכל על הצד השמאלי
זו דרך לתאר ואנחנו הולכים להשתמש בדיאגרמות האלה
לאורך כל המצגת כדי
להמחיש את הכוח — אנחנו רואים עיגול
ושתי נקודות — כשהנקודה נמצאת בקוטב הצפוני
זה אפס, וכשהיא בקוטב הדרומי זה אחד
זה הביט הקלאסי עם שני מצבים. עכשיו qubit הוא ה-
יחידת המידע בעולם הקוונטי
וכאן אנחנו מקבלים את התמונה המלאה
שהכדור הוא לא אפס ולא אחד
ואנחנו יכולים לשים אותם במצב סופרפוזיציה
יש לנו טריק מיוחד שעומד לרשותנו
לא רק שאנחנו יכולים למקם אותם בכדור
אלא תדמיין שכל אחד מהם
הוא כמו ירח קטן
שנמצא בכדור ואנחנו יכולים לסובב את הירח
אז כאן אתה רואה
שהכדור התחתון סובב מעט
ולכן אתה רואה קצת כחול
וורוד ואנחנו יכולים לסובב אותו עד הסוף
אז הנה סיבוב של מאה ושמונים מעלות
אז יש לנו את המושג הזה של פאזה שהקוונטי מעניק לנו
שלוש על-כוחות שמתבטאים ב-qubit
הם הכוחות של סופרפוזיציה
הכוח של אינטרפרנציה
והכוח של שזירה
אז בוא נמחיש אותם — עקרון הסופרפוזיציה הוא בעצם
די פשוט להבנה
אז הכוכב שבצד שמאל
הוא או קוטב צפוני — אפס, או קוטב דרומי — אחד
ואם נחבר את שני המצבים האלה
עכשיו יש לנו qubit בסופרפוזיציה שמחזיק גם
אפס וגם אחד בו-זמנית — צפון
ודרום. עכשיו הדיאגרמה הימנית זהה
אבל עכשיו אנחנו הולכים לעשות טריק קטן
אנחנו הולכים להפעיל gate — quantum gate
על מה שעשינו כאן — זכור
אנחנו יכולים לשנות עכשיו, אנחנו יכולים
לסובב את הירחים הקטנים האלה, נכון?
אז סיבבנו אותו מאה
ושמונים מעלות ועכשיו יש לנו אחד
אז עכשיו כשאנחנו מחברים אפס פלוס אחד אנחנו מקבלים
מצב סופרפוזיציה
אבל שים לב שזה שונה
וזה שמשמאל — אנחנו עדיין
אפס ואחד אבל עכשיו עם מצב מסובב
בשביל האחד. עכשיו זה הולך להיות מאוד חזק
כדי אז למנף דבר שני ממש מעניין שהוא
עקרון האינטרפרנציה
וזו לא פעולה שאנחנו יכולים לבצע בעולם הקלאסי
של הביטים — אז הנה בדוגמה הזאת יש לנו
אפס ואחד משמאל פלוס
המצב החדש שיצרנו
שהוא גם אפס ואחד
אבל עם הירח המסובב הזה — כשאנחנו עושים את זה עכשיו
אנחנו גורמים לשני המצבים האלה להתערב
ושים לב שמשהו ממש מעניין קרה
ביטלנו את מצב האחד
ונשארנו עם מצב האפס
עשינו את זה כי גרמנו למצבים להתערב
אז ההזדמנות הבאה שיש לנו עכשיו
היא כמה מצבים אנחנו יכולים ליצור
והדבר היפה בקוונטי הוא שאנחנו יכולים ליצור מספר אקספוננציאלי
של מצבים — אז בוא נסתכל על מערכת שיש לה
חמישה qubit — במקרה הזה אנחנו מתארים את ה-qubit האלה
כ-qubit עצמאיים, נכון? אתה רואה אותם משמאל
אפסים ואחדים, והם מתרבים — יש לנו חמישה
מהם — אז מספר המצבים שאנחנו יכולים ליצור למטה בר-
מחשב קוונטי, שמיוצג על הכדור מימין
הוא שניים בחזקת
מספר ה-qubit שיש לנו — במקרה הזה יש לנו חמישה
אז שניים בחזקת חמש זה שלושים ושניים מצבים
אז אנחנו רואים שלושים ושניים מהירחים הקטנים האלה
שים לב שבמקרה הזה לא שילבנו
שום פאזה — הם כולם ורודים. ההיבט החזק של
שימוש בתכונה הזאת שנקראת שזירה בעולם הקוונטי
הוא שאנחנו יכולים ליצור עכשיו מצבים
כמו זה שמתואר מימין
שבהם יש לנו את השילובים האלה של ורוד
וכחול — שבהם המצב הזה לא יכול להיות מתואר
כמכפלה עצמאית של
חמשת ה-qubit האלה — במקרה הזה
כיוון שיש לנו שלושים ושניים מצבים
מה שזה אומר לנו הוא בעצם משהו עמוק מאוד